let's go to camus
who is maybe less concerned with murder
and more concerned with suicide
as a way to explore human nature so he
is uh probably my favorite
existentialist probably one of the more
accessible existentialists
and like you said
one of the people who didn't like to
call himself an existentialist so what
are your thoughts about camus what role
does he play in the story of
existentialism so
i find camus totally fascinating i
really do and for years
i didn't teach caimu
because the famous
thing that you're referring to the myth
of sisyphus which is a sort of essay
it's published as a book
super accessible really fascinating he's
a great writer really engaging
the opening line is something like
there is but one truly significant
philosophical question and that is the
question of suicide yeah and i thought i
can't teach my
18 year olds you know like
yeah i i just thought that's terrible
like how can i
i mean it's not wrong like that's a but
do i want to bring that into the
classroom yeah and and so i read it i
read the the essay i avoided it for a
long time because just because of that
line
and i thought i'm not going to be able
to make sense of this in a way that will
be helpful for anyone
but finally one year maybe seven or
eight years ago i sat down to read it i
thought i've i've gotta really confront
it
and i read it and it's incredibly
engaging i mean it's really really
beautiful and and kamu was against
suicide which just turns out to be good
you know
i was happy about that
but he he has a bit of a bleak
understanding of what human existence
amounts to
and so uh in the end he thinks that
human existence is absurd
and it's being absurd as a kind of
technical term for him
and it means that
the episodes in your life
and your life as a whole
presents itself to you as if it's got a
meaning
but really it doesn't
so there's this tension between the way
things seem to be
on their surface
and what really turns out to be true
about them and and he gives these great
examples like you probably remember
these he says
there you are you're walking uh along
the street and you there's a plate glass
window in a building and through the
window
uh you you see somebody talking on a
telephone i mean i imagined it as a cell
phone but camus
for didn't
uh but you see somebody talking on a
cell phone and he's animated he's
talking a lot as if things really meant
something
and yet camus says it's a dumb show
and it's not dumb in the sense just in
the sense that it's stupid it's dumb in
the sense that it's silent
it presents itself as if it's got some
significance and yet its significance is
withheld from you and he says that's
what our lives are like
everything in our lives presents
themselves to us as if it's got a
significance but it doesn't it's absurd
uh and and then he says really what our
lives are like are like they're like the
lives of sisyphus
just
day after day
you do the same thing
you know you wake up at a certain time
you get on the bus you go to work you
take your lunch break you get off
my i have a colleague who once said to
me something like this it was about
october or so in the fall semester i
said how's how's it going dick he said
well you know how it is i got on the
conveyor belt at the beginning of the
semester and i'm just going through
and that's that's the way my life is and
camus thinks that that
experience which you can sometimes have
reveals something true about what human
lives are like our lives really just are
like the life of sisyphus who rolls this
boulder up the hill from morning till
night and then at night he gets to the
top and it rolls back down to the bottom
over the course of the night he walks
back down and then he starts it all over
again
and he says sisyphus is condemned to
this life like we're condemned to our
lives
but we do have one bit of freedom
and it's the only thing that we can hang
on to
it's the freedom
to stick it to the gods who put us in
this position
by embracing this existence rather than
giving up and committing suicide and i
thought well it's
kind of a happy ending
but but but i also thought it it's a dim
view of what our our existence amounts
to
so i i think there's something
fascinating about that
but what i
came to believe and i tried to write
about this once i know you read the
thing about aliveness that i published
once that's secretly a criticism of
camus i don't think i mentioned camu in
there but i think camus has got the
phenomenon wrong
or he's missed some important aspect of
it because in camus view
when you experience your day as sort of
going on in this deadening way and
you're just doing the things that you
always do the way you always do them
for kamu that reveals the truth about
what our lives are
but i think there's some aspect at least
for me and maybe maybe
he just didn't feel this or didn't have
access to it maybe others don't but for
me there's an extra part to it which is
somehow
that yes that's the way things are
and it's inadequate
and there's something that's missing
from that aspect of our existence
that could be there
and it feels like our lives are not
about just putting up with that and
sticking it to the gods by embracing it
but seeking that absence part of it the
part that's
recognizable in its absence
in your experience of that
and that's that's what i think i i think
we do have the experience of the
presence of that in moments when
you feel truly alive
and that's what you mean by the word
aliveness which is a fascinating and a
powerful word yeah that's what i mean by
it i mean i think
most people can recognize moments in
their lives
when they really felt alive and it could
happen in a moment when
you know i don't know maybe miles davis
felt it in that moment when he was
responding to herbie hancock's cord or
maybe
you feel it in that moment where you
grab for the hand on the first date and
the gesture is reciprocated
or maybe you feel it in some moment when
you are
doing a kind of peak athletic thing or
watching somebody else do a peak
athletic thing
but i think there are moments when we
when it feels like it's not like
the way
camus is describing things
and it's better because of that
you